bonjour à toutes et à tous ravis de vous
retrouver et éminemment heureuse
d'animer cette table ronde avec avec nos
invités alors on vit on cette en cette
rentrée une période assez particulière
on espère laisser derrière nous 18 mois
extrêmement difficile avec des
fondamentaux économiques finalement
plutôt bon
reste à savoir si nos concitoyens
partagent partage cet avis la perception
n'est pas toujours exactement la même et
puis avec une dimension dont on a
beaucoup parlé ce matin la question
européenne naturellement puisque au
modem on s'est naturellement que pour
rivaliser avec les grandes puissances
que sont notamment les états unis et la
chine nous avons besoin de l'europe pour
nous protéger pour protéger ses forces
de vivre protéger ses entreprises et
nous avons besoin de souveraineté la
crise l'a à nouveau prouvé alors on a
ouvert ses universités de rentrée sur la
question climatique est bien évidemment
ces enjeux et l'enjeu climatique l'enjeu
social qui sont devant nous impose
finalement de réfléchir à ce que doit
être notre modèle de croissance au
niveau français bien sûr mais aussi au
niveau européen alors nos invités noces
nos cinq invités qui sont là vont nous
éclairer sur toutes ces questions alors
je vais vous les présenter en quelques
mots d'abord je voudrais accueillir
bénédicte jézéquel qui nous vient du
morbihan donc une une locale bénédicte
josé voilà vous pouvez l'applaudir
bénédicte et codirigeant de silva d'hec
qui est une pme innovante bretonne
tellement innovantes qu'elle exporte à
l'international et qu'elle a mis au
point un procédé
particulièrement innovant pour fabriquer
un bois composite obtenus grâce à de la
farine de bois et du plastique si je ne
me trompe pas et donc bénédicte nous
parlera de son point de vue
d'entrepreneurs française éventuellement
d'aider des contraintes des freins en
qualité exposé comment elle les a
dépassées et les a tous les atouts de la
france dans la dans la compétition
internationale
merci à vous d'être là jean marc borello
merci d'être là sur marc borello le
présente plus mais on va le quand même
le présenter jean marc borello et le
confondateur dans marche membre du
bureau exécutif
il est aussi parce qu'il a un agenda
particulièrement chargé
le président fondateur du groupe sos
competo et skhira qui rassemble plus de
vingt mille personnes vingt mille
salariés et qui part d'un
motif qui finalement
illustre votre engagement au service de
la chose publique c'est que quel que
soit son parcours ses revenus comment
permettre à chacun d'avoir accès à des
services de qualité en lien avec ses
besoins essentiels qu'il s'agisse du
grand âge de la question de l'éducation
ou encore du logement
militants l'entrepreneuriat au service
de l'intérêt général vous nous direz ce
que doit être pour vous le rôle de
l'entreprise et sa contribution
philippe martin qu'on ne présente plus
non plus mais je vais quand même essayer
de le faire nommer plus jeune économiste
de france en 2002 de mémoire aujourd'hui
président délégué du cae donc rattachée
directement au premier ministre ayant
contribué très fortement au programme
économique du président macron qui nous
nous fera part de son analyse sur la
situation économique actuelle et puis
nos deux locaux l'étape donc
marie-pierre vedrenne députée européenne
conseillère régionale vice présidente de
la commission commerce international au
parlement européen spécialiste
évidemment des sujets commerciaux mais
aussi qui a beaucoup d'ambitions sur la
question de la présidence française et
qui nous donnera son éclairage sur ces
questions et puis enfin
[Applaudissements]
donc il ya les morbihannais
il ya ceux d'île et vilaine on voit bien
que la bretagne est très très bien
présentée alors comme il ya des
yvelinois aussi je sais que notre
secrétaire général aura le droit à une
standing-ovation jean-noël barrot
[Applaudissements]
jean-noël barrot économiste diplômé
dachau ses professeurs au et mighty mais
aussi député des yvelines conseiller
régional vice-président de la commission
des finances et secrétaire général du
modem qui nous parlera à la fois de ce
que le gouvernement a fait depuis 2017
mais aussi ce que sont les perspectives
et les sujets qui sont particulièrement
défendue par part par le mouvement
démocrate est corse est un spécialiste
de la question de l'évaluation et qu'il
vient de remettre un rapport à jean
castex à sa demande sur la question
justement de deux là l'aterrissage de la
territorialisation du plan de relance je
pense qu'il nous dira aussi un mot des
atouts et des enjeux pour les mois qui
viennent donc sans plus tarder je vais
passer la parole tout de suite à notre
économiste philippe martin pour qu'il
nous fasse un petit point à la fois sur
la situation telle qu il l'entend et
puis peut-être nous dira aussi au regard
justement de la situation des finances
publiques ce que peut-être ce que doit
être
l'intervention sur un sur un plan d'eau
sur un point de vue social de la
puissance publique au regard des dettes
notamment provoqué par par la question
du coc vite merci beaucoup merci à vous
merci pour l'invitation donc oui je fais
un petit point trop du ctif sur là où en
êtes vous avez dit ça va mieux est ce
que les français s'en rendre compte soit
quand même qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
débats sur la gestion sanitaire il y en
a eu beaucoup moins sur la gestion
économique de la crise que vit je crois
que les français reconnaissent à quel
point le quoi qu'il en coûte
l'absorption du choc
sur les ménages les entreprises sur
l'emploi a été quand même bien gérée par
le gouvernement alors on peut toujours
trouver à redire ou l'armée je crois
qu'il ya plutôt un consensus sur le fait
qu' on a bien fait de protéger fortement
les entreprises les ménages et l'emploi
je dirais quelques points clés un petit
peu de publicité d'ailleurs pour un
travail qui va paraître la semaine
prochaine du conseil d'analysé
économique où on regarde justement où on
en est aujourd'hui de la situation
financière en particulier des tpe pme
c'est un travail très original parce que
on a scruté le cent mille comptes
bancaires de tpe pme alors de manière ne
vous inquiétez pas complètement
anonymisées évidemment mais ça nous
permet de voir aujourd'hui des données
de mois d'août où on en est parce que on
est dans une situation évidemment très
particulière au sens où à la fois il ya
le rebond et puis il ya la fin des aides
et donc c'est ce moment un peu
particulier par lequel joue bien passé
mais qui est un moment de fragilité
alors ce qu'on voit c'est que la
situation financière des entreprises en
particulier tant que nous on regarde tpe
pme est bonne en moyenne c'est à dire
qu' il n'y a pas de problème de
liquidités trésorerie et ça c'est le pge
évidemment le prêt garanti par l'état et
en terme de situation de dette
à nouveau en fait la moyenne est bonne
c'est à dire que la dette bancaire nette
des entreprises des tpe/pme en moyenne
n'a pas augmenté je reviendrai
évidemment parce qu'il ya des zones de
fragilité sur les ménages là encore et
ça c'est aussi beaucoup le chômage
partiel un certain nombre de transferts
sociaux
le pouvoir d'achat et c'est assez
exceptionnel dans une crise de d'aussi
grande ampleur
nana a continué à augmenter il ya il
n'est pas une très forte donc la
question pour les économistes évidemment
c'est à quel rythme c'est cette épargne
va être dépensé
on avait très peur qu'une épargne
contraintes deviennent une épargne de
précaution s'est pas encore complètement
clair ce qui va se passer de ce point de
vue et puis du côté de l'emploi là
encore est entre guillemets les scans
listes doivent battre un peu leur couple
on était on était très pessimiste sur
l'emploi je vous rappelle que on disait
il va y avoir un million de deux pauvres
en plus pourquoi pas ce qu'on anticipait
une hausse du chômage à 10 voire plus et
c'était comme ça qu on en arriver au
chiffre de 20 millions c'est parce que
c'est parce qu'on a eu heureusement et
l'emploi se tient bien alors il ya des
mères ou disons des zones un petit peu
je crois de où il faut faire attention
sur les entreprises je disais les tpe
ont été très bien protégé
les hôtels et restaurants par exemple on
était très bien protégé c'est très clair
et on le voit de manière assez directe
les pme et dans certains secteurs il ya
des zones de fragilité il ya des
entreprises dont on voit que la tête il
ya plus d'entreprises qui sont dans des
situations financières délicates que à
la peur la crise c'est une augmentation
beaucoup moins importante que ce qu'on
pouvait craindre mais il ya ce sujet de
la dette d'un certain nombre
d'entreprises qu'il faudra avoir en tête
sur les ménages
on le sait
l'épargnant elle a été constituée mais
de manière assez inégalitaire c'est à
dire que les deux premiers déciles de
revenus les 20% les plus modestes n'ont
pas épargné et même plutôt un peu d
épargne et moi j'ai beaucoup milité pour
le fait sur le fait qu'il fallait
peut-être faire davantage et en
particulier les jeunes dont on avait
regardé aussi les comptes bancaires sur
lesquels il y avait des situations de
précarité alors les jeunes l'emploi des
jeunes c'est très cyclique dire que là
en ce moment quand ça va mal ça va plus
mal que le reste de la population et que
ça va mieux ça va encore mieux que la
population donc là sa remontée de ce
point de vue on peut rester on peut
rester optimiste mais je pense qu'il ya
cette question des jeunes qui d'ailleurs
va être très importante évidemment dans
dans la campagne et puis sur l'emploi il
ya quand même le sujet qu'il reste
aujourd'hui 200 mille personnes en
équivalents temps plein qui sont en
chômage partiel donc je pense qu'il ya
des points d'attention des points de
fragilité qu'il faut avoir bien en tête
mais le point global c'est que quand
même la situation est bien meilleure que
je qu'on pouvait craindre il ya encore
un an mais vous avez parlé de l'europe
et de l'international c'est très clair
que la crise sanitaire on le sait très
bien ne sera pas terminée en france tant
qu'elle ne sera pas terminée ailleurs
donc on a payé trop cher le fait de
penser que tout ça était dernière nous
évidemment il ya encore ce sujet
d'attention qui plane au vote une deux
points pour pour finir qui sont plus des
points disons structurelles et plus de
long terme ou c'est un et on a une
ministre de l'éducation à ce propos je
pense que la question d'éducation va
être absolument fondamental et est entre
guillemets je pense que ça n'est plus un
sujet simplement du ministre de
l'éducation c'est à dire que c'est ta
main c'est un sujet aussi pour le
ministre de l'économie pour l'économie
on le voit il ya les difficultés de
recrutement et on les retrouve à la fois
pour les très hautes qualifications et
les très basses qualification qui
évidemment demandé des réponses
extrêmement différente
des questions de savoir être
certainement pour les passes
qualification et puis la question
scientifique de il ya un rendement très
élevé aux formations techniques et
scientifiques
et clairement il ya un sujet qui n'est
pas encore complètement résolu deuxième
sujet on l'a vu dans la crise alors
c'est un sujet entre le politique et
l'économie et c'est l'économie politique
c'est le sujet de la défiance
qui est un sujet très des reines en face
à ça ne s'est pas macron sait même pas
c'est quelque chose qu'on voit de
manière très structurels en france de
défiance vis-à-vis du gouvernement des
institutions de la science y l'avis même
des autres français ce qui s'est passé
pendant la crise et que je vous fais pas
confiance pour porter bien le masque etc
et donc on a demandé plein de
réglementation tout le monde était très
content qu'ils aient détruit très
stricte pendant le premier confinement
mais c'est ce qui explique aussi que
l'économie française pendant le premier
confinement parce qu'on a mis toutes ces
réglementations très dur très
restrictive a chuté plus que les autres
donc la confiance et la défiance parce
qu'elle rend plus difficile la
négociation un acte d accord implicite
dans les entreprises et c'est à un coût
économique très élevé et cette première
crise du 21e siècle celle annonce
d'autres crises où on devra la gérer ou
la société les gouvernements devront la
co gérer
et ça on sait pas très bien faire en
français je pense que ce problème qui
les départs et il est pas réglé donc
voilà éducation et confiance je sais que
vous voulez que je parle de la dette
donc je peux dire que cette troisième
sujet c'est pas le sujet qui m'empêche
de dormir aujourd'hui certainement
expliquer pourquoi je pense que le choc
que vides il faut
que
il doit être absorbé par de la tête
parce que c'est un choc de dépenses qui
n'est pas pérenne en revanche on a bien
vu tout le monde nous demande des
dépenses publiques plus importantes
santé éducation et moi le premier et
donc jeu est là et je me suis exprimé là
dessus je pense que je n'étais pas en
faveur d'une réforme paramétrique sur
sur sur les retraites je pense que la
donne a changé
je pense qu'il faudra passer par là
entre e-mails fouillis si on veut du
sucre et il va falloir un peu de ça
l'est aussi et et parce que si on veut
une augmentation des dépenses publiques
et on voit bien en ce moment il ya
beaucoup de demandes il va falloir en
effet je pense le le faire et ça c'est
quelque chose qui est différent avant qu
vide et après que vite ça n'est pas le
choc lui même que vides prince et
l'augmentation des dépenses publiques
qui est demandé et donc ça signifie que
si on veut ne pas creuser davantage la
dette il y aura besoin évidemment d'une
baisse des dépenses publiques par
ailleurs si on pas une augmentation des
impôts et je pense quand même que le
plus évident le plus naturel ce sera
cette question des retraites
merci beaucoup merci pour ce pour ce
tour d'horizon et nous remettre un
certain nombre de fondamentaux en tête
bénédicte jézéquel vous avez donc il y
as en 2001 créé co créer une entreprise
qui aujourd'hui extrêmement
grâce à une innovation majeure et qui
désormais est installé à la fois sur le
territoire français européens et même
internationale en partant du morbihan
est-ce que vous pouvez nous faire part
de la foi de votre expérience
d'entrepreneur et votre vision
aujourd'hui sur comment faire finalement
pour qu'il y ait d'autres silva dec en
france
je me permet de rebondir sur quelque
chose que vous avez dit c'est
à l'issue du premier confie alors du
premier confinement l'économie française
a plus plongé peut être que d'autres
économies moi j'ai une usine en
allemagne et une usine en france
effectivement pendant la période du 1er
confinement on sait pas du tout arrêté
en allemagne alors qu'on a été à l'arrêt
pendant trois à quatre semaines en
france ce qui fait que finalement lors
de l'exercice 2009 1 on était quand même
en croissance en allemagne et en juste
enfin légère diminution en france donc
effectivement on a vu la différence de
comportement alors mon pour ce qui est
de mon entreprise autrement donc nous on
fabrique du bois composite en dans les
années 80 19 2 me dont s'est rapproché
d'un bureau d'études américain qui avait
lancé une technologie qui consistait à
mélanger de la fibre de bois et du
plastique vierge recyclé pour en faire
des profils est destiné à l'aménagement
extérieur or l'intérêt de la techno
c'est que ça nous permet de faire des
produits parfaitement imputrescible sans
qu'il y ait besoin de rajouter deux
traitements font biocides et donc ce
sont des produits extrêmement durable
dans le temps et donc lors d'un voyage
professionnel aux états unis ont avec un
associé on avait eu donc vent de cette
techno et on
bon on a et on s'est rapprochés ce
bureau d'études et qu'il n'avait pas de
licencier en europe et donc on s'est
décidé à se lancer en fait dans ce
nouveau marché en europe alors bon
j'avais vu que c'est ats-unis mon
associé à londres enfin on avait une
petite culture internationale auparavant
donc on était habitué à faire des
transferts de technologie états unis va
la france est
donc bon mais c'était quand même à
nouveau un français l'ancien milieu du
bâtiment nous ce n'est pas un milieu que
connaissent et ont travaillé dans
l'industrie plastique auparavant et donc
on a été lorsqu on a créé notre
entreprise on a voulu s'implanter enfin
moi je suis bretonne donc moi j'ai voulu
revient plein mais terre et en fait on a
trouvé une communauté de communes qui
nous a accueillis dans le morbihan on a
été extrêmement bien accueilli enfin on
parle souvent des difficultés de
l'entreprise afin de créer son
entreprise en france en jeu les cris en
2001 moi je trouve que c'est un pays
cocagne j'étais vraiment très surprise
par tous les systèmes d'accompagnement
qu'on pouvait qu'on peut avoir on a eu
un maire qui a fait qu'on serait un
bâtiment adapté à nos besoins qui arrive
qui a réuni en fait je dirais les
différentes collectes par les
différentes collectivités enfin on a été
accompagnée par la dréal par l'ademe
dans la région
je trouve que en tout cas on a eu tout
un écosystème qui s'est mis autour de
nous pour nous aider en fait à créer
l'entreprise bon après ça tu es c'était
une affaire assez compliqué puisque
c'était un nouveau produit en plein
déboires technologique etc mais
finalement on a été enfin cet
accompagnement nous a permis vraiment de
passer les premières étapes
donc ensuite mon notre entreprise enfin
on vend essentiellement donc des profils
et enfin des planches chez les
distributeurs professionnels tels que
point p enfin gedimat et puis on fait un
peu de distribution grand public tels
que leroy merlin par exemple
notre et ont fait de l'international
aussi enfin on a toujours enfin on dans
notre adn
on aimait bien on avait l'appétence pour
pour le goût du voyage enfin et on
aimait bien découvrir de nouvelles
cultures donc on a toujours on en fait
c'était nous on était les premiers en
europe donc on a réussi en fait à
s'introduire dans des réseaux de
distribution en allemagne europe de
l'est enfin petit peu partout en europe
et donc en 2014 mon entreprise en france
était vraiment devenu trop petit enfin
les locaux étaient devenus beaucoup trop
petit donc on avait hésité en fait entre
rester en france a grandi en france ou à
l'étranger
et finalement pour des raisons pour un
ensemble de raisons je dirai pas ce que
notre premier marché c'était allemagne
mais aussi parce que ben il faut avouer
que la fiscalité est un peu plus
attractif pour les industriels en
allemagne qu'en france
on a fait le choix de s'implanter en
bavière
qui est l'une des régions quand même les
finalement les les plus cher si on
désire enfin le pib le plus développé en
europe et mais on se disait que
enfin on a été très bien très bien
accompagné en bavière comme en france
d'ailleurs pour pouvoir porter une usine
en allemagne soit peu près les mêmes
dispositifs on est accompagné par ce
qu'on appelle invest in bavaria il se
trouvait aussi le local etc donc c'est à
peu près grosso modo la même chose
on a notre point faible lorsqu'on s'est
dit lorsqu'on arrivait en allemagne
c'était le recrutement parce qu'on est à
40 km du siège d'audi enfin dans un
territoire à peu près 2 3% de chômage
mais la différence entre l'allemagne et
la france là pour coup c'est que les
jeunes enfin il ya quand même une
appétence pour l'industrie en fait aller
travailler en usine c'est
voilà c'est normal
on les ouvriers sont aussi mieux payés
en allemagne qu'en france globalement
alors on va vous parler des mini jobs
mais si finalement c'est le seul moyen
en bavière il est largement plus élevé
que ce que le salaire en france
le louvre idéalement finalement revient
plus peut-être un peu plus cher parce
que les taxes les charges patronales
sont assez élevés par contre le cadre
allemand revient beaucoup moins cher que
le cadre français puisqu'on est toujours
à 20 % de charges patronales contre 40%
en france voire un peu plus pour les
industriels parce que dans les styles il
faut savoir que ça atteint 48% donc
c'est énorme donc là tu veux sincèrement
l'industrie du bois je sais pas comment
ils peuvent s'en sortir en france
mais
est donc mais par contre on a des
comment dire d une fiscalité qui est
plus attractive en france pour en
allemagne parce qu'on n'a pas tous ses
impôts de comment dire de production
enfin mais pas suffisamment parce qu en
allemagne en a pas
mais effectivement la convergence est
meilleur parce que lorsqu'on a démarré
il y avait à fin mai mais vous les avez
pas encore diminuer suffisamment
c'est en cours c'est en quoi mais il ya
encore du travail mais c'est meilleur
c'est beaucoup mieux ses meilleurs amis
oui parce que de tenir on a le problème
c'est que lorsqu'on fait lorsque nous on
a décidé de partir mais c'est un
ensemble de raisons parce qu'on avait
des clients là bas c'était un gros
marché etc mais il ya aussi 7,7 ce
problème de fiscalité mais lorsqu'on est
parti en fait est que ça fonctionne bien
mais on n'a pas forcément envie de
revenir parce que la croissance se fait
là-bas aussi quoi et qu'on a mis tous
temps qu'on a fait tout un gros travail
pour pouvoir pour voir s'installer là
bas maintenant on est allé dans des
territoires qu'on connaissait un moi
j'achète tous mes matières premières en
europe je enfin je suis une européenne
convaincue aussi j'ai essayé d'acheter
un petit peu parfois en asie du sud-est
ça fonctionne pas très bien parce que
dès qu'il ya des ruptures de défaire
venir par avion vous maîtrisez pas la
qualité l'inox chinois s'est pas inox
aux français enfin c'est finalement
acheté en asie du sud-est quand on est
encore on a une société comme la mienne
de 45 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires et 100 personnes c'est pas si
simple que ça donc on est quand même on
achète toujours d'acheter quand même
plutôt en local qu'en notre terrain de
jeu c'est l'europe au final donc une
finalement une pme bretonneau bavaroise
c'est sa leader européenne de son marché
sur une base extrêmement innovante sur
un secteur qui ne cesse de se développer
qui est l'économie circulaire et
cherchant à s'approvisionner en circuit
court donc finalement vous êtes
l'exemple même d'une entreprise qui
contribue à son échelle à cette économie
responsable que nous appelons de nos
voeux au niveau européen donc merci à
très peu de chose en france a par
exemple lancé hier c'est quelque chose
qui nous a vraiment
on a un bureau d'études avec à peu près
enfin sur une centaine de personnes il
ya sept ou huit ingénieurs qui
travaillent enfin et des chercheurs et
le cr et a vraiment un dispositif
incitatif qui permet de faire le premier
pas lorsqu on embauche un chercheur et
commencez pas finalement qu'est-ce qui
va trouver
merci beaucoup
merci bénédicte
[Applaudissements]
jean marc borello vous êtes le militant
par excellence de l'entrepreneuriat au
service de l'intérêt général alors
justement pour rebondir sur les propos
de bénédicte vous vous avez un discours
très construit sur la question justement
au regard des besoins de ce que peut
être le rôle à la fois des entreprises
mais aussi du privé lucratif ou non
lucratif et puis du du service public
est ce que vous pouvez nous en dire
quelques mots
bonjour et merci de votre invitation il
s'est construit avec le temps en poste
rationalise ans qu'on avait réussi à
l'oublier en sociaux qu'on devait jouer
donc c'est pas très glorieux comme
discours construit mais en tout cas ces
quarante dernières années effectivement
le sujet de l'économie du partage de la
richesse de l'entreprise d'intérêt
général etc reviennent de manière assez
récurrente avec en tout cas depuis
quelques années me semble-t-il un vrai
mouvement de consolidation alors pour
aller vite économie classique ou
sérieuse que d'autres connaissent mieux
que moi et puis l'économie sociale pas
tout à fait rien 12% du pib 14 % de
l'emploi en ce moment si j'ai bien
compris mais fondée sur une différence
statutaire la différence un tuteur étant
d'un côté les entreprises de capitaux
les gens sérieux qui représente ma
voisine de droite et puis tout ce qui
était très simplement associations
coopératives mutuelles et fondations qui
était l'économie sociale avec sans doute
l'idée derrière ça que les zincs était
d'offres capitaliste ou quant au corps
spongieux gorgée du sang des
travailleurs pardon ça date un peu et
que les autres étaient de doux rêveurs
sympathique qui dépenser de l'argent
public sans être capable de le créer
d'ailleurs on retrouve globalement sur
l'échiquier politique puisque c'est le
dernier métiers complémentaires et
bénévoles que j'exerce l'idée qu' une
partie de la classe politique était doué
pour créer de la richesse
faire fonctionner des entreprises avoir
des résultats distribuer des dividendes
ça pour aller vite c'était la droite et
puis l'autre était plutôt doué pour la
partager équitablement est le problème
c'est que les deux se rencontrent et pas
et donc on a eu des périodes où vont
créer plus de richesses d'autres ont
créé plus de dépenses et ça a créé un
système alternatif mais pas très pérenne
l'idée selon laquelle l'économie et par
d'augmenter du point de vue micro en
tout cas peut à la fois créer des
richesses et à la fois répartir
équitablement les richesses créées c'est
un mouvement qui s'est amorcée il faut
rendre
à césar ce qui lui appartient d'abord
par une loi sur l'économie sociale qui
était une loi de benoît hamon auquel on
a réussi à faire entendre l'idée que ce
n'était pas un problème de statut et que
pour reprendre ce qui m'a valu beaucoup
de succès dans le monde associatif
cette époque là l'idée que les statuts
ne faisait pas la vertu j'avais
l'habitude de rajouter il ya des
associations de malfaiteurs des
coopératives d'imbéciles des mutuelles
aux frais de gestion extravagants donc
on ne forme pas l'intérêt ou l'impact
d'une entreprise sur ses statuts et il y
à des entreprises de capitaux qui ont un
impact formidable sur les salariés sur
l'environnement sur les circuits courts
et donc il n'y a pas d'un côté les
capitalistes qui font des profits et de
l'autre côté les joyeuses animateurs
associatifs qui font des dépenses donc
la loi mon a permis de considérer qu'un
certain nombre d'entreprises classiques
si j'ose dire avec des actionnaires
pouvaient être des entreprises d'intérêt
général et ça a été fait dans ce set loi
et puis une autre loi plus récentes sur
lequel notre ami jean noël a pas mal de
travailler avec olivier grégoire et
quelques autres qui est la loi pacte qui
disait pour se rapprocher si j'ose dire
dans l'autre sens que des entreprises
classiques avec des ex ionnaires des
capitaux des réussites une
internationalisation pouvait aussi se
donner des objectifs qui n'était pas que
financier et c'est la loi pacte avec le
cortège des entreprises à mission etc
des de la raison d'être qu'on peut
aujourd'hui mettre dans ses statuts donc
j'ai le sentiment avec le temps passe et
que les choses deviennent plus
raisonnables
je les dires de vienne
en même temps la capacité de créer des
richesses parce que un titre personnel
j'ai toujours eu plus de difficultés à
créer de la richesse qu'est la répartir
ça prend plus de temps la cré et c'est
monté une entreprise qui fait des
résultats et faire en sorte qu'avec ses
résultats en puisse
équitablement partagé cette richesse ou
équitablement à avoir des prix
différenciés en fonction du revenu de
ceux dont on s'occupe donc je pense que
nous allons dans le bon sens si encore
du travail je suis encore très fan des
fondations actionnaires je n'y suis pas
parvenu pendant ce quinquennat mais j'ai
quelques camarades sur les prix y
compris parlementaire sur lesquels je
peux compter puisque je trouve que les
fondations actionnaires est un outil
très utile et en europe du nord
extrêmement important des grands groupes
industriels le velux et quelques rolex
et quelques autres appartiennent à des
fondations actionnaires on a créé un
dispositif n'est peut-être pas allé
assez loin sur ce sur ce créneau là et
donc le sentiment qu'on nous allons dans
le bon sens on voit aussi dans le bon
sens ce paiement des impôts de
production je vous promets que il ya une
suite à ce qui a été fait donc je crois
que nous avons avancé et c'est plutôt
extrêmement positif et le dernier point
c'est qu'effectivement un certain nombre
de services dits d'intérêt général
peuvent être
fournies par des entreprises qu'elles
soient d'ailleurs lucrative ou pas le
groupe sos genre des hôpitaux alors on
sait pas que le mil le le système
non lucratif gère des hôpitaux non c'est
pas des cliniques ce sont des hôpitaux
c'est pas écrit dessus si c'est public
privé lucratif ou privés non lucratifs
mais nous gérons des hôpitaux on avait
la bonne idée aussi de gérer des maisons
de retraite ce qui dans la période qui
vient de s'écouler était plutôt sportif
et c'est là qu'on peut essayer d'être un
peu imaginatif sur le plan économique
par exemple les maisons de retraite à
grands traits
c'est le public qui sont très peu cher
avait une tendance à ne pas être
suffisamment entretenu avec suffisamment
de salariés en avait tendance à
considérer qu'un fantôme de m maisons de
retraite publiques commençait à
ressembler à des hospices et puis le
privé lucratif s'était réservée la part
lucrative c'est à dire des maisons de
retraite plus cher mieux équipée avec
plus de best-of de personnel ni il y a
cinq ou six ans considérant que ça
n'était pas strictement interdite nous
avons décidé d'appliquer des tarifs
différenciés dans nos maisons de
retraite qui prenait en compte le revenu
de ceux que nous accueillons s'était pas
totalement autorisée mais pas totalement
interdits on l'a fait la cour des
comptes dans un rapport qui doit sortir
la fin du mois va dire que nous avons
bien fait de le faire mais c'est
typiquement des modèles économiques où
on offre le même service la même qualité
de service dans une entreprise qui du
coup fonctionne bien et a des résultats
mais en prenant en compte le revenu déjà
on sera très compliqué on appelait ça
surloyer solidaire pour ne pas être
traitée d'offres libéraux pour nos
camarades qui est un peu le système du
monde hlm mais le fait est que c'est un
des moyens de répondre un enjeu
extrêmement important et qui sera
d'ailleurs majeur dans le projet de loi
de finances qui est la prise en charge
de nos aînés donc encore une fois qu'on
soit public privé lucratif privés non
lucratifs sap a une grande importance
dans l'ensemble des car il faut être
capable de mesurer l'impact de
l'entreprise et c'est sur cet impact
qu'on est capable de faire des choix y
compris des joues au public de fiscalité
ou dead pour aller dans les deux cas et
d'ailleurs nous avons créé avec jean
moulin un impact en que donc un think
tank sur l'impact avec quelques
universités dont sciences pour quelques
autres qui a pour objet de mesurer
l'impact des entreprises à la demande
évidemment des entrepreneurs pour
essayer de corriger ce qui ne va pas et
d' améliorer ce qui peut l'être donc
encore une fois un sentiment plutôt
optimiste avec une particularité c'est
que malgré cette crise malgré un secteur
qui a été particulièrement impacté
puisque en ce qui nous concerne les
hôpitaux les ehpad ont eu à gérer un peu
en première ligne les sujets qu vide et
bien le secteur est plutôt résilient
et objectivement
grâce aux aides publiques y compris sur
les sur les ehpad nous avons passé la
crise nous avons plutôt sur embauché
grâce aux ségur de la santé dans des
conditions qui sont un peu meilleurs que
par le passé donc encore une fois la
crise c'est aussi un moyen d'avancer de
modifier ses pratiques d'apprendre mais
je pense que c'est un un moment dont
nous nous sortons collectivement plutôt
mieux prévu il n'y a pas que les
économistes qui s'était qui était
inquiet les chefs d'entreprises aussi et
à la fin de l'histoire je pense que la
gestion publique de cette affaire quoi
qu'on en dise a été exemplaire et nous a
permis de passer la crise et aujourd'hui
de rebondir merci beaucoup
cette crise elle a également été
l'occasion nous faire comprendre à quel
point la question de la souveraineté
l'indépendance c'était absolument majeur
et l'europe a souvent été accusé de
naïveté sur un certain nombre de
questions notamment sur ces sujets de de
règles de concurrence ou du commerce
alors marie pierre est une immense
spécialiste des questions
de commercial et omc et pas qu'eux et à
la veille finalement de cette présidence
française de l'union européenne dont on
attend énormément puisque on connaît
l'engagement du président de la
république sur sur cette question je
voulais avoir ton point de vue et est
ton analyse de la situation merci
beaucoup mode bonjour à tous et à toutes
très heureuse d'être avec vous et et de
pouvoir rebondir aussi justement à tous
les témoignages qui ont été dit avant je
pense que c'est c'est important je
reviens effectivement d'abord sur les
constats qu on partage tout ce que le
président de la république partagé bien
avant aussi la crise du coc vite quand
dans le discours sur la sorbonne dans la
lettre aux européens il appelle de ses
voeux une europe beaucoup plus uni et
quand vous évoquez vos problématiques à
l'intérieur du marché c'est ce qu'on
veut faire beaucoup plus juste est
beaucoup plus souveraine donc tout ce
travail maintenant c'est comment on va
convaincre tous nos collègues européens
qu'il faut véritablement avancer et
aller de l'avant et construire les
notamment juridiques mais aussi
budgétaire pour pouvoir répondre à ces
objectifs là
justement pour répondre à la crise je
crois que je reviens pas sur la
situation sanitaire où on a beaucoup
critiqué l'europe au début mais d'un
point de vue économique il faut rappeler
historique l'engagement et l'adoption du
plan de relance permis parce que le
président de la république angela merkel
se sont mis d'accord et justement ont
dessiné en quelque sorte ensemble la
politique du quoi qu'il en coûte il faut
se rappeler les divergences qu'il y
avait à l'époque quand on était dans
plein débat à la fois au conseil à la
fois parlement rodin sur l'adoption de
ce plan de relance ce n'était clairement
pas acquis et pour autant nous y sommes
arrivés et nous avons ce plan de relance
qui maintenant doit se déployer dans
l'ensemble de nos territoires et qui
doit permettre de bâtir une relance une
relance justement en écho avec le titre
de notre débat qui soit juste
socialement qui soit responsable
écologiquement et qui soit aussi source
d'innovation pour justement aussi
contribuer au partage de la richesse
alors tu as évoqué modeler sujet les
sujets commerciaux et effectivement
cette volonté d'avoir une europe
puissance et répondre je me focaliserai
juste sur deux points pour répondre à la
question sur une économie plus
responsable de levier qu'on souhaite
absolument avancer au cours de la
présidence française le devoir de
vigilance ou on a une initiative
française c'est-à-dire faire en sorte
que justement on le lait à l'échelle
européenne parce qu'on le voit bien nos
chaînes de valeur elles ne sont pas
toujours résiliente il y à de la
concurrence déloyale à la fois sur le
volet environnemental à la fois sur le
volet social les droits du travail donc
il nous faut absolument avancer et cite
une priorité et nous avons maintenant
une proposition qui arrive sur la table
de la commission européenne et le
parlement européen est à l'avant-garde
sur ces sujets pour véritablement y
arriver ça sera bien évidemment un enjeu
pour avoir une économie responsable mais
aussi pour garantir des conditions de
concurrence plus loyale autre levier
c'est le mécanisme carbone on en a
beaucoup parlé là aussi un évidemment
c'est un an je essentiel pour répondre
aux changements climatiques mais c'est
un enjeu aussi on laborde peut-être
moins nous côté parlement parce que on
sait que ça posera des divergences mais
pour le remboursement de la tête ce
mécanisme carbone il l'a aussi pour
visée de contribuer au budget européen
aux ressources propres qui aborderont
aussi cette question un autre axe
peut-être qui est extrêmement important
dont on a parlé dans différentes tables
rondes sur la une économie responsable
c'est aussi maintenant le rôle des
plateformes et des gens du numérique et
là encore pendant la présidence
française on a des enjeux fondamentaux
sur la régulation de ces géants du
numérique à la fois en terme économique
à la fois en termes de contenu parce que
ça a été abordée aussi on passe
habituellement une logique de propagande
mais une logique d'ingérence dans notre
société européenne donc c'est un enjeu
fondamental sur lequel on veut
absolument avancer pendant la présidence
française et puis parce que madame vous
l'avez bien évoqué au travers de votre
expérience il ya tout ce travail qui est
fait sur la scène internationale il ya à
l'intérieur de notre propre marché des
conditions de concurrence déloyale sur
le volet social sur le volet fiscal un
enjeu fondamental de la présidence
française sur le volet social c'est le
salaire minimum adaptés à chaque état
membre de l'union européenne on le
précise à chaque fois parce qu'on se
fait souvent
attaqué par nos oppositions dès qu'on
parle de salaire minimum mais non c'est
vrai mais véritablement répondre à
l'enjeu que vous avez aussi esquissé
c'est à dire que en europe il ya quand
même une personne sur six qui vit en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté donc il
nous faut aussi bâtir une vraie europe
sociale avoir un modèle de convergence
qui soient tirés vers le haut et c'est
l'enjeu du salaire de minimum c'est
l'enjeu aussi d'un rapport qui est porté
par notre collègue sylvie brunet sur les
travailleurs des plateformes là encore
c'est essentiel il s'agit pas de pointer
du doigt les plateformes et il s'agit
véritablement quand il ya un conflit
qu'elles prennent pleinement leurs
responsabilités parce que ces
travailleurs doivent eux aussi
bénéficier de tous leurs droits que ce
soit le droit justement à la protection
le droit à plus tard à la retraite etc
il faut qu'on puisse avancer sur ces
enjeux donc nous sommes pleinement
engagés à la fois les dépits d'euros
d'armes à la fois avec les collègues à
l'assemblée pour porter cette justement
future économie responsable
merci beaucoup marie pierre et
et on connaît l'engagement et l'énergie
de marie-pierre et de l'ensemble de la
délégation venue au parlement européen
pour faire avancer toutes ces questions
alors si la situation aujourd'hui est
encourageante sans rien nier des
difficultés qui demeurent cdu évidemment
à la manière dont la crise a été gérée
mais également sur un certain nombre de
l'avancée de mesures qui ont été portées
par le gouvernement et jean noël en tant
que garant de
l'évaluation des politiques publiques et
acteurs jean marc borello l'a rappelé
notamment de la loi pacte est ce que
jean noël tu pourrais nous faire un
petit retour sur sur les principales
dispositions en répondant peut être
également à bénédicte sur la question
des impôts de production et la baisse
des impôts de production et puis
esquisse et les perspectives ski se
semblent être les priorités pour pour
les mois et les années qui viennent
merci beaucoup aux modes d'abord je
voudrais vous dire que je suis très
honoré et très heureux d'être aux côtés
de philippe martin et jean marc borello
ce que vous le savez peut-être pas tous
mais chacun dans leur domaine
d'expertisé ils ont été des inspirateurs
de ce que nous avons fait depuis 2010
est donc écoutez bien ce qu'ils disent
aujourd'hui parce que ça préfigure
peut-être un certain nombre de choses
que nous ferons demain 13h aussi de
retrouver ma complice marie-pierre
vedrenne qui dans notre petit groupe de
députés européens et celle qui suit les
sujets économiques elle vient d'en
parler avec brio et très hâte de
rencontrer bénédicte dont nos amis du
morbihan nous ont dit le plus grand bien
et qui a effectivement cette très belle
entre cette très belle aventure
entrepreneuriale familiale qu'elle nous
a raconté moi je voudrais vous donner
quelques points sur lesquels à mon avis
on a un peu avancé et sur lesquels on
peut aller sans doute un peu plus loin
en reprenant peut-être le sujet sur
lequel au point on l'a laissé avec
marie-pierre une économie responsable
c'est aussi et c'est c'est du ressort de
la négociation européenne c'est aussi
une économie dans lesquelles les
entreprises payent et les entreprises
d'ailleurs lé ménages mais les
entreprises en particulier payent les
impôts qu'elles doivent j'aurai pour
raconter je voulais parler de ça en
particulier parce que le groupe modem à
l'assemblée a été le premier à défendre
l'idée de la taxe gaza et a été le
premier aussi inspiré par un certain
nombre de travaux menés par philippe
martin a proposé l'impôt minimum sur les
sociétés et vous voyez que grâce à
l'impulsion des manuels macron à
l'énergie déployée par bruno le maire on
est sur la voie en tout cas j'ai
l'impression qu'on y est de 2 delà d'un
accord sur la taxation minimum à un
impôt minimum sur les sociétés pourquoi
c'est important ce sens ce plancher sans
ce taux minimal les grandes entreprises
optimisent et choisissent évidemment les
juridictions les pays où l'impôt est le
plus faible pour y loger leur production
ou leurs activités en fonction de la du
bénéfice fiscal de qu'elles peuvent en
tirer évidemment ça ça pose un problème
majeur puisque
de justice sociale puisque les pays
les pays sont privés des recettes
nécessaires au financement de la
protection sociale mais ça crée aussi
une forme de d'inégalité entre les
grands groupes qui peuvent optimiser
et choisir ainsi les meilleures
localisations où loger leurs profits et
les jeunes entreprises celles qui vont
créer les emplois de demain qui vont
créer de la productivité et qui elles
parce qu'elles sont jeunes parce
qu'elles sont un peu plus petites n'ont
pas accès à ces choses là donc pour des
questions de justice et d'efficacité
il fallait mettre fin à cette situation
et on est presque au bout même si ça va
encore supposer un certain nombre de
discussions
deuxième sujet la question de la
transition écologique et la marie pierre
l'a évoqué aussi ce qui est très
remarquable c'est le plan de relance
d'une certaine manière la crise de l'aco
vide nous aura être grâce à la grâce à
l'accord décroché par le président de la
république
grâce au plan de relance qui a été mis
sur pied par le gouvernement et qui a
adopté au parlement d'accélérer un
certain nombre de transition et voudrais
partager avec vous deux exemples de mon
petit tour de france puisque à la
demande du premier ministre me suis
rendu dans chacune des 13 régions de
france métropolitaine en déplaçant dans
des bassins d'emploi qui était fragile
avant la crise et qui étaient touchés
par la crise et qui risquait donc de
cumuler si je puis dire les difficultés
c'était d'abord l'exemple du havre où
nous sommes rendus début mai quelques
jours seulement après la fermeture de la
centrale à charbon conformément aux
engagements pris par la france et par le
président de la république la centrale à
charbon du havre qui était opéré par edf
elle est sur le port du havre moi je
connaissais pas le port du havre il faut
voir le port du havre c'est
gigantesque port qui est une zone
industrielle très importante hélas la
centrale à charbon avait fermé ses
portes il y avait 140 salariés au moment
de la fermeture il y en a un certain
nombre qui vont être redéployés
reclasser il y en a une dizaine qui va
rester sur le site pour le démantèlement
enfin évidemment des questions sociales
qui sont posés par cette fermeture
vous traversez la rue littéralement
quelques dizaines de mètres en face de
la centrale à charbon vous avez un
gigantesque chantier
c'est le chantier de siemens gamesa
siemens gamme eisa au havre ce sera le
premier site industriel dédié aux
énergies renouvelables en france puisque
c'est danser sur ce site qu'on a
semblera les gigantesques éoliennes
offshore qui certes ont fait parler un
peu d'elle dans l'actualité récemment
mais qui emploieront à terme
750 personnes et notamment des jeunes
sans qualification des quartiers du
havre où les taux de chômage sont
particulièrement élevés avec un coup de
pouce de france relance du plan de
relance pour qui a permis aux chantiers
qui avaient pris de retard du retard du
fait de la crise de l'aco vide de rester
rentable malgré le retard accumulé le
deuxième exemple c'est l'exemple de
béthune où nous sommes rendus avec la
petite équipe avec laquelle je
travaillais
quelques semaines après la fermeture de
bridgestone ou bristol vous vous
souvenez c'est ce pse très très très
inquiétant puisqu'il a concerné 8 163
salariés avec une usine légendaire de
pneus qui après 60 années d'activité à
fermer brutalement ses portes cette
année heureusement il ya une
mobilisation très forte de l'état du
territoire pour essayer de reclasser le
maximum de ses salariés et quand nous y
sommes allés le site était fermé donc
nous ne l'avons pas visiter mais nous
avons visité une autre entreprise une
entreprise une autre entreprise
familiale qui s'appelle groupe
atlantique groupe atlantique c'est une
théorie aujourd'hui qui a une présence
internationale et qui fabrique des
chaudières et des pompes à chaleur et
donc nous on leur demande alors pas trop
dure la crise et ils disent ben non
parce que grâce à ma prime rénove le
dispositif d'accompagnement à la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
nous avons vendu des chaudières nous
avons vendu des pompes à chaleur si bien
que nous avons ouvert 50 postes à des ex
princeton je vais citer ces deux
exemples vous dire que le plan de
relance au havre devant la centrale à
charbon à béthune aux portes de
bridgestone a permis d'accélérer des
transitions et de réconcilier d'une
certaine manière développement
économique d'un bassin d'emploi sinistré
avec la transition écologique
justice fiscale transition écologique
égalité femmes hommes et lutte contre
les discriminations c'est le troisième
point que vous les partager avec vous
c'est là aussi un sujet donc auquel on
doit être extrêmement attentif parce que
c'est une question de justice mais c'est
aussi une question d'efficacité quand on
a 50 % de la population
qui est féminin ou féminine et 30
pourtant seulement des chefs
d'entreprise qu'ils le sont c'était une
égalité d'accès à un droit à une forme
d'émancipation mais c'est aussi et les
études le montrent une forme
d'inefficacité économique pourquoi se
priver d'un tel vivier de talents
pourquoi dans des entreprises
aurions-nous une sur représentation des
hommes qui ne correspond pas ni à la
clientèle ni au vivier de talents ni aux
poules des investisseurs potentiels sur
ce sujet de l'égalité femmes hommes lors
de la première d'une des toutes
premières réformes du quinquennat qui
est la loi sur l'avenir professionnel
sur le choix de son avenir professionnel
j'ai plus le nom exact en tête sur la
liberté de choisir son avenir
professionnel de muriel pénicaud qui a
réformé l'apprentissage on a instauré le
principe d'un indice que les entreprises
doivent publier d'égalité salariale de
manière à ce que les mauvais ou en tout
cas les bonnes pratiques soient
valorisés et que les pratiques un peu
datés soit mise en avant pour que les
entreprises se réforme c'est évidemment
une étape intéressante mais je crois que
sur ce sujet je parle de l'égalité
femmes hommes parce que c'est un exemple
de ce que l'on a fait mais sur sur
toutes les questions de discrimination
il faudra qu'on aille beaucoup plus loin
et puis le dernier sujet est là je
rejoins tout à fait ce qu'a dit jean
marc
on est c'est fini le temps où on
opposait l'entreprise avec
le monde associatif le monde de
l'économie sociale et solidaire et grâce
à des acteurs comme jean-marc d'un côté
grâce à des chefs d'entreprises engagées
comme bénédicte comme d'autres de
l'autre nous regardons désormais les
organisations comme étant des acteurs du
changement de la transition du progrès
indépendamment de leur statut et
sur la question de l'association des
salariés au
partage de la valeur comme au pouvoir
dans l'entreprise
l'une des conquêtes de ce quinquennat
c'est que nous sommes allés beaucoup
plus loin sur la question de
l'intéressement de la participation et
de l'actionnariat salarié donc là c'est
le monde traditionnellement de
l'entreprise qui se rapproche des
modèles de l'économie sociale et
solidaire qui associe beaucoup mieux et
beaucoup plus les salariés les
collaborateurs aux décisions
stratégiques et aux bénéfices engendrés
par les entreprises et donc s'agissant
de l'intéressement et la participation
dans la loi pacte que citer jean marc
nous avons réduit le forfait social
c'est-à-dire les impôts que les
employeurs paye sur les sommes qui sont
versées au titre de l'intéressement et
la participation
nous avons aussi faciliter les
mécanismes d'actionnariat salarié et
nous l'avons fait un peu plus encore
pendant la crise où là aussi le forfait
social sur les versements donnant lieu à
l'acquisition par les salariés de parts
de leur entreprise a été réduit ce qui
est une très bonne chose mais nous
sommes encore très loin du compte
puisque la part des salariés qui sont
associés au capital de leur entreprise
aujourd'hui en france est encore
beaucoup trop faible alors moi comme
économiste au départ je me méfiais de
cette idée un peu française de
l'actionnariat salarié au passage
l'intéressement et la participation
contrairement à ce qu'on dit souvent
c'est c'est peut-être une idée
gaullienne c'est peut-être de gaulle
qu'il a beaucoup poussé mais celui qui a
rédigé l'ordonance de 59 qui fige ou
quand la qui instaure le régime de
l'intéressement et la participation
c'est paul bacon ministre du travail est
maire p démocrate pendant neuf ans à qui
on doit également
l'instauration du salaire minimum et
donc sur ces sujets là
nous avons fait beaucoup mais il reste
encore beaucoup à faire et je pense que
nous devons collectivement réfléchir aux
propositions qui pourront en celle que
nous présenterons aux français le
président de la république s'il est
candidat comme nous le souhaitons
présentera de lait devant les français
en avril prochain parce qu'il est
essentiel que dans le monde qui vient
les salariés les collaborateurs de
l'entreprise
puisse avoir le sentiment et la
perception d'être aussi responsable
d'être aussi associé aux décisions et
d'être aussi je dirais associée à la
performance et aux fruits de la
prospérité sans quoi nous finirons une
fois encore par retrouver des
oppositions stériles entre ceux qui
disent qu'il faut viser la prospérité et
ceux qui disent au contraire comme le
rappelait jean marc tout à leur donnant
il faut d'abord se s'inquiéter de
partager les fruits de la croissance
avant même d'en avoir créé les
conditions voilà ce que je voulais
partager avec vous je vous remercie
merci beaucoup jean noël
alors on va prendre un certain nombre
d'interventions en plusieurs salves si
vous voulez bien et surtout je vous
demanderai de resserrer vos
interventions pour que le maximum de
gens puissent prendre la parole et
surtout pour que nos invités et le temps
d'y répondre
oui bonjour bruno voyer donc élu en
bretagne en sur la côte d'émeraude
je souhaitais faire un petit clin d'oeil
à un bénédicte
jézéquel parce que mon rêve quand elle
parlait de du morbihan et de la bavière
que je connais bien
c'est que la bretagne un jour dans une
république décentralisée vraiment
décentralisée soit la bavière de la
france je dis ça assez souvent géré sans
rigoler parce que je pense que on a la
même configuration la même culture les
mêmes à toute la bavière et demain dans
une république centriste décentralisée
enfin abouti
la bretagne soit notre soit la bavière
bon ça c'est un petit clin d'oeil moi je
souhaitais aborder deux questions
que je constate au quotidien à titre
d'élu mais surtout au t2 professionnelle
puisque jacques aux ça fait 20 ans que
je travaille dans développement
économique et d'accompagnement des
entreprises et de la ss d'ailleurs il ya
deux sujets qui ont été qui sont latents
depuis très longtemps mais qu'on était
énormément renforcé depuis la crise donc
depuis un an et demi c'est la
rémunération des salariés les conditions
de travail des salariés parce que ça a
été évoqué dans une intervention c'était
déjà un sujet mais aujourd'hui on croise
tous des chefs d'entreprise des artisans
des commerçants beaucoup de salariés
dans certains secteurs du service et du
btp ne veulent plus travailler dans
certaines conditions à certains horaires
le week-end et c'est donc la première
question c'est la rémunération des
salaires bas et des conditions de
travail donc il va falloir y passer
parce que sinon on va plus avoir de main
d'oeuvre mais ça nécessiterait que le
client final que nous sommes tous payent
plus cher le produit ou le service
première question les deuxième question
je le rejoins tu dirais c'est
je lis responsable dans l'appellation
c'est donner du sens et de la valeur aux
salariés en particulier pour les jeunes
générations c'est à dire on ne peut plus
être aujourd'hui simple plombier
électricien ou tout ça mais pourquoi on
fait ce travail à quoi ça sert et qu'est
ce que ça apporte à la société dans les
deux sens du terme la société avec un
grand s et la société comme entreprise
voilà donc mr la rémunération et le sens
et les valeurs qu'est ce qu'on fait très
bien merci beaucoup
oui bonjour donc une question un jour
noël peut-être à marie-pierre par
rapport à l'enjeu de la rue
relocalisation de la production et de la
transition écologique est-ce que c'est
pas le moment justement en europe de
reparler d'une taxe carbone sur les
produits importés alors je sais pas si
voilà ce que vous avez dit mais j'aurais
voulu développer un petit peu peut-être
ce point pour pour les enjeux autour du
climat merci
merci
alors martine le gall on m'a dit de
faire court je suis de la banlieue de
l'autre tout de la banlieue de guidel de
l'autre côté de la laïta alors c'est pas
cours pour le coup et expatrié à paris
depuis quelques belles années alors moi
j'ai deux questions pour le coup alors
je suis désolé parce que ça va être plus
long la première question je voudrais
revenir sur la question de la dette et
la deuxième ça concerne plus les
subventions et
l'écologie la rénovation énergétique
alors la première concernant la dette on
peut que se féliciter de la gestion de
la crise
et que la crise sanitaire par la banque
centrale européenne on a évité une crise
de liquidités alors on a aujourd'hui on
est dans une phase de sortie alors on
voit avec côté réserve fédérale
américaine c'est le début des
spécialistes par deux parlent de taper
alors en europe on est plutôt dans la
phase ii recalibration alors ce qui se
passe sur le plan économique et
j'aimerais en savoir un petit peu plus
puisqu'on a des économistes autour de la
table aujourd'hui c'est que on est dans
une situation de taux d'intérêt assez
durablement bas une inflation
dont on ne sait pas si elle est
conjoncturelle ou structurelle
aujourd'hui avec ce que j'appelle des
des conséquences des ânes expected quand
ces cônes 6 à savoir peut-être des
phénomènes de bulles sur un certain
nombre d'actifs et qui touche tout le
monde y compris les particuliers ici
puisque on peut avoir des bulles
immobilières certains endroits des
bulles sur certains actifs financiers
comment est-ce qu'on en sort ça génère
aussi des inégalités est ce qu'on sait
bien fléché tout le plan de relance vers
justement cette rénovation énergétique
et c est ça m'amène à la deuxième
question pour le coup sur la rénovation
énergétique puisque j'ai eu l'occasion
récemment palois d'ici de monter un
dossier de subvention pour une pompe à
chaleur pour ma maman et on retrouve le
mille feuille territorial pour ses
phénomènes de subvention avec des
agences au milieu alors c'est
extrêmement lourd moi j'ai commencé il
ya un an on a installé la pompe à
chaleur cette semaine pour être sincère
avec vous et d'autre part par contre il
manque peut-être des éléments de nature
technique pour les particuliers parce
que on veut améliorer
les diagnostics énergétiques des maisons
mais en tant que particulier c'est
difficile de s'y connaître à la fois on
pourra chaleur en pignon à rénover en
sous sol
ah là aussi améliorer la performance
énergétique à isoler je cherchais le
terme donc il ya vraiment des sacrés
questionnement cours et je compte sur
les économistes parce que je suis aussi
hamon à mon humble d'une nouveau
économiste de formation et je crois
qu'on a beaucoup de choses à remettre à
plat et à revoir merci beaucoup je vais
tout de suite passé la parole à philippe
martin pour vous éclairer sur un certain
nombre de questions qui ont été posées
merci je sais pas si je répondrai à
toutes les questions sur rémunération
oui je pense que la question des bas
salaires elle se pose est par ailleurs
quand en effet on a du mal à recruter 1
et que de myst vous dire un ba oui il
faut que le prix s'ajustent et que s'il
ya une demande de travail qui est
supérieure à l'offre et ben il faut
certainement en effet que les et les bas
salaires augmentent avec quand même 2
sujet d'attention c'est que sur un
certain nombre de personnes très peu
qualifiés
la question des bas salaires elle doit
se doit se conjuguer à celle aussi de la
formation
et la possibilité de s'adapter aux
entreprises et donc je pense qu'on peut
pas ne pas mettre les deux sujets en
même temps et par ailleurs il reste vrai
que une augmentation des bas salaires
justement pour des personnes très peu
qualifiés a quand même
quand même un impact sur le taux de
chômage des personnes qualifiées donc et
c'est assez délicat et donc je pense que
la sortie par le haut c'est en effet les
questions de formation vous avez parlé
aussi des contrats
la scellier par exemple la réforme de
l'assurance chômage
on voit que ce qui est une autre option
c'est de changer le type de contrat
qu'on offre c'est-à-dire des contrats
plus longs on sait à quel point dans
l'hôtellerie la restauration un cd
contrat extrêmement précaires qui sont
en partie générée par
l'assurance chômage qui donne pas toutes
les bonnes incitations à la fois aux
salariés et aux chefs des chefs
d'entreprise
moi je voudrais juste dire un mot aussi
sur la question de la taxe carbone parce
que je m'inscris en faux quand même sur
l'idée qu'on aurait que la taxe carbone
sur les produits importés c'est bien
parce que c'est les chinois qui vont
payer ça n'est pas vrai ce sera nous qui
paierons c'est quand même taxe sur la
consommation et il faut pas se tromper
d'objectif
le mécanisme alors c'est pas vraiment
une taxe carbone mais en fait ça y
ressemble mais le mécanisme d'ajustement
aux frontières
l'objectif ça doit être un objectif
environnemental et moi je ne crois pas
trop au fait que ça doit financer des
dépenses publiques autres et c'est
l'objectif c'est un objectif d'abord
environnementale et même pas simplement
de non plus de protection industrielle
je me méfie quand même beaucoup de ce
type de raisonnement à la fin la taxe
carbone ça doit être un objectif
environnemental et avant de la mettre
sur un certain nombre de produits
importés je vous rappelle que c'est un
mécanisme d'ajustement et donc ça
signifie qu'il faut mettre aussi une
taxe carbone
sur les secteurs qui aujourd'hui n'en
ont pas ou très peu donc ça va reposer
aussi la question va pas mettre une taxe
carbone sur les voitures importées tant
qu'on met pas une taxe carbone sur la
production de voitures qu'on produit en
europe donc il va falloir aussi qu'on
fasse notre propre travail de ce point
de vue d'un mécanisme de taxe carbone
qui est beaucoup plus large parce que là
les économistes croient sont tous
d'accord la taxe carbone ça n'est pas
suffisant mais c'est absolument
nécessaire pour pour pour la pour la la
transition et dernier point sur taux
d'intérêt je comprends l'inquiétude je
pense que en effet et moi ce qui
m'inquiète ça n'est pas tellement le
fait que les taux d'intérêt remontent
très très rapidement
ou que l'inflation remontera très
rapidement en revanche ce qui est vrai
et ça c'est une inquiétude c'est les
bulles spéculatives que ça peut générer
et je pense que on est on il y à un
risque en effet d'une crise financière
liée à une bulle spéculative qui serait
une sorte de dommage collatéral des
politiques monétaires qui ont amené mais
qui était absolument nécessaire je suis
d'accord il ya une sorte d'interrogation
sur comment on en sort sans changer
d'air soit un problème de crise de dette
publique soit une bulle une bulle
spéculative
merci beaucoup jean noël
oui sur le sujet des rémunérations
je pense que philippe a raison de dire
que la formation est essentielle
il semblerait que des annonces soit
imminente sur le sujet pour essayer
d'apporter un certain de réponse
la question de l'intéressement de la
participation de l'actionnariat salarié
est une autre réponse et moi je souhaite
qu'on puisse
profiter si je puis dire de cette
situation de difficultés de recrutement
pour avancer plus loin sur ces sujets et
je voudrais simplement vous dire aussi
que sur cette question on a réfléchi
avec les camarades de la commission des
finances et on a fait une proposition
peut être l'avez vous vu passer dont on
va discuter avec le gouvernement pendant
la semaine qui vient qui consiste à dire
qu'il faudrait
défiscaliser les pourboires
pourquoi parce que
[Musique]
parmi les raisons qui expliquent les
difficultés de recrutement dans hôtels
cafés restaurants mais aussi d'autres
secteurs il ya la question de la
rémunération comme l'a dit philippe
c'est pas évident de relever
immédiatement les rémunérations pour des
entreprises qui sont quand même dans une
situation même si elles ont survécu à la
crise qui n'est pas nécessairement très
solide alors pourquoi ne pas faire
levier sur la générosité des français
aujourd'hui les français ne déposent
plus de pourboire parce que en général
on paye en cartes et on n'a pas vraiment
dispositif d'application pour déposer un
pourboire ces applications elles
existent mais pourquoi est-ce qu'elles
sont pas déployés c'est simple parce que
il ya une tolérance tout française au
pourboire en liquide pour que en gros ni
le restaurateur ni le professionnel ne
les déclare c'est comme une sorte de
gratification qui échappent en quelque
sorte au calcul de l'impôt et donc si
soudainement les restaurateurs se
mettent à installer des applications
pour collecter les pourboires
là ça devient un flux numériques et là
tout d'un coup ça devient fiscalisés et
donc l'étape indispensable si on veut
que très rapidement puisse se
généraliser
le pourboire ce que je pense que si
amoureux de moins en moins de pourboire
c'est pas que les gens pas tellement
envie d'en donner c'est parce que on a
la petite pièce à rajouter à la fin 2 à
la fin du repas il faut passer par cette
étape de défiscalisation peut-être de
manière transitoire de manière bien
cadré mais c'est une manière aussi de
faire participer le consommateur sur une
base volontaire à l'amélioration de la
rémunération des professionnels du
secteur
bénédicte je voulais vous donner la
parole sur les sujets de recrutement
également savoir si vous vous étiez vous
étiez confrontés à des difficultés
particulières notamment sur la question
de la formation
écoutez donc
en termes de recrutement pour ce qui est
de l'encadrement bon on fait des
produits qui s'inscrivent dans l'air du
temps issus de farine de bois de
plastique recyclé donc quand je veux
dire on fait des produits qui ont du
sens pour les jeunes si je puis dire
donc au final on arrive à recruter des
talents maintenant il faut pouvoir les
garder en ce qui concerne ensuite les
opérateurs enfin en minimes existe même
des outils digitaux enfin je vais pas
faire de plus de publicité pour sa tel
ou tel outil mais qui permettent en fait
d'aller capter quand même d'aller
trouver trouver des personnes donc si on
utilise les nouveaux outils numériques à
ce stade nous on s'en sort à peu près
bon après on on a en fait mon la société
tourne correctement donc on a une
politique de rémunération aussi ont fait
appel à tous les ingénieurs et sociale
qui est disponible ce fectivement que
son intéressement supplément
d'intéressement chèques-cadeaux chèques
vacances etc mais au-delà de ça là il ya
un problème qui va nous arriver je pense
mais enfin en tout cas en bretagne c'est
le problème du logement et là c'est
enfin vous pouvoir des jeunes qui
veulent venir mais trouvent pas de
logement et là c'est hélas je pense que
il ya eu des politiques incitatives au
niveau du logement ça fait une dizaine
d'années enfin je pense loi scellier etc
qui ont poussé les particuliers à
investir et à construire des maisons
pour louer mais actuellement nous nos
jeunes ils savent pas où se loger et moi
je vais enfin on imagine même là je suis
en train de me dire est ce qu'il
faudrait pas que j'investisse dans ma
commune des petits collectifs pour
accueillir les jeunes c'est celle où ça
va devenir le problème noir en tout cas
de la bretagne
parce qu'il ya un flux de population
vers la bretagne je ne peux pas je ne
connais pas la situation du logement
dans les autres territoires en tout cas
nous on va avoir ce problème là qui nous
arrive de façon massive
donc le sens n'est pas un frein mais en
revanche le logement il était passé pour
pouvoir recruter il faut effectivement
avoir le travail le salaire mais faut
que le jeune puisse enfin le jeune ou la
personne puisse se loger et actuellement
on est en pénurie mais extrêmement élevé
merci beaucoup jean marc borello vous
étiez une entreprise a mission avec
raison d'être depuis bien avant
l'invention de cette terminologie est ce
que vous la question la question du sens
a toujours été au coeur de votre
engagement est ce que vous voyez chez
les plus jeunes aujourd'hui un
changement de pied justement sur 7 sur
cette dimension de sens
je crois quand on voit le changement de
pied de manière à peu près comme des
nues sur les 35 dernières années si vous
vouliez date est objectivement le serait
ce double de taille tous les quatre ou
cinq gars donc on recrute en moyenne de
2500 personnes par an on a plutôt un
afflux de candidats objectivement avec
la particularité que par rapport à
certaines entreprises en tout cas il ya
quelques années on n'était pas tout à
fait ligne et pour des jeunes très
diplômés sortants de brillantes écoles
de chaussée ou ailleurs ça venait ça n'a
jamais été une difficulté pour recruter
c'est à dire qu objectivement mes
camarades de chef d'entreprise je me
disais parts
chez toi pour travailler plus et gagner
moins donc le slogan n'était pas mauvais
un détail près donc c'était c'est vrai
il ya eu un véritable regain ça existe
aussi chez des gens qui sont moins
jeunes qui ont fait une carrière et
heureusement pour nous parce que quand
la maison grandi c'est bien le jeune
mais il faut avoir quelques plus âgés
pour encadrer tout ça on a de plus en
plus de gens que vous faites première
partie de leur vie dans l'entreprise
classique voire dans la haute
administration et qui décide de
rejoindre une entreprise d'économie
sociale lorsque ils ont impayés la
résidence principale la résidence
secondaire que les enfants sont partis
et que pour la dernière partie de leur
vie ont envie de se faire plaisir quitte
à gagner moins d'hommes je crois que le
sujet du sens où le 10e adam est
parfaitement essentiel et ça permet
d'attirer les meilleurs des meilleurs
écoles par ailleurs les sujets du
logement je suis en train de faire
construire des logements dans le grand
test pour loger des infirmières parce
que évidemment on a comme tout le monde
des postes d'infirmières disponible dans
nos hôpitaux et que le fait est qu'il ya
pas mal de frontaliers qui vivent dans
les départements proches en lorraine et
qui vont bosser au luxembourg et donc
les prix sont élevés et pour pouvoir
accueillir ce type de personnel je
décidé de refaire du capitalisme à la
papa sans capitaux ont reconstruit des
immeubles de logements pour accueillir
des infirmières donc je crois que il ya
à la fois le logement et la nécessité
pour l'entreprise de prendre
la pleine mesure des besoins des
salariés
si certains nombre de secteurs sont
démunis c'est sans doute parce qu'ils
n'ont pas su faire évoluer les horaires
faire évoluer les salaires faire évoluer
le sujet du logement il existe depuis 20
ans pour les frontaliers
il existe aussi pour les saisonniers
s'il n'y a pas de logement c'est sympa
de les serveurs sur une plage de saint
tropez mais si pour se loger en dépenses
4 fois ce qu'on gagne en étant serveur
ça marche pas ici a pas de serveur même
les plus belles plages de saint-tropez
où d'ailleurs par donc je suis pas très
bon tourments vous l'entendez
c'est même les plus belles plages ne
pourront pas fonctionner s'il n'y a pas
de serveurs donc ça fait partie des
responsabilités de l'entreprise ce
domaine et lorsque ses salariés ses
actionnaires et ses clients accordent
une grande importance à l'impact il vaut
mieux que le chef d'entreprise
face avec sinon l'entreprise risque
d'être elles mêmes en difficulté
merci beaucoup
marie-pierre sur la question des relaxes
relocalisation
peut-être juste pour rebondir et pour
aussi aller dans le sens et avoir des
exemples breton est effectivement c'est
les mêmes enjeux et quand justement il
ya grégoire dernièrement et est venu à
saint malo et bruno tu connais bien
aussi ce territoire c'est exactement les
problématiques qui ont été évoqués et
vous avez raison madame quand on se
déplace quand je me déplace à travers la
bretagne à chaque fois ce qui est dit
c'est la formation l'adaptation le fait
que certains métiers ont certains jeunes
et énormément aussi beaucoup de préjugés
ne connaissent pas la réalité du monde
du travail que ça aussi c'est des
efforts sur lequel nous devons avancer
et la problématique du logement et à
chaque fois mise en avant spécifiquement
sur nos côtes bretonnes - à l'intérieur
de nos terres bretonnes donc c'est un
enjeu fondamental sur la relocalisation
et la question de tanguy la suite aussi
aux chocs du coc vide la commission
européenne a établi une liste de 145
produits véritablement où justement elle
estime qu'il faut qu'on relocalise qu'on
avance quelque peu à l'essai mais vous
vous entendez beaucoup parlé à thierry
breton sur les semi conducteurs on
entend beaucoup parler sur l'hydrogène
donc il ya une identification de
secteurs stratégiques parce qu'on le
sait bien aussi on ne va pas tous
localisés en europe et une
relocalisation aussi avoir des chaînes
de valeur qu'ils soient plus résiliente
c'est quelque chose qui s'inscrit dans
le temps long ça ne se fait pas d'un
claquement de doigts donc par contre
l'union européenne en est pleinement
pleinement consciente et on travaille
sur ces enjeux au travers justement tu
l'évoqué mode de cette notion
d'autonomie stratégique et comment
l'union européenne n'est pas dépendante
on pense tout le temps à la chine n'y a
pas que la chine sur d'autres matières
premières sur d'autres enjeux on n'est
pas que dépendance vis-à-vis de cet
enjeu notamment basse heureux si on
prend l'énergie aussi c'est un sujet
fondamental et juste pour rebondir sur
un sur le mécanisme carbone
effectivement parle pas de taxes pour
éviter de tomber dans les systèmes
blocage institutionnel
je vous rejoins sur sur ce que vous avez
dit monsieur martin lors l'enjeu est
effectivement quand même pour nous
parce qu'on le voit bien c'est notamment
un sujet sur lequel on se fait beaucoup
attaqué pour nos oppositions sur le
remboursement du plan de relance sur la
dette est ce qu on veut démontrer aussi
quand même et l'action de renaissance
est ce que disait jean noël c'est la
question de la juste prix et du juste
accès à notre marché intérieur
donc c'est un c'est un enjeu fondamental
mais on a conscience que le mécanisme
carbone est avant tout un outil
environnementale et vous avez raison il
encore moi je le vois bien avec tous les
échanges que avec les entreprises
bretonnes elles ont peur des
conséquences et de la mise en oeuvre de
ce mécanisme qui peut être politiquement
essentiel justement en terme de messages
mais comment il va se concrétiser c'est
tout l'enjeu et c'est tout le travail
qu'on doit réellement menée par ce que
il faut aussi qu'ils aient une comptable
compatibilité pardon avec les règles de
l'omc et qu'au final nous n'ayons pas
des mesures de rétention et que un
mécanisme qui sur le principe et l'idée
est très intéressant et des effets au
final négatif dans le quotidien de nos
entreprises
je pense qu'on peut applaudir
marie-pierre
merci merci mille fois à nos invités
merci beaucoup pour cet échange au
combien éclairant et cet échange avec la
salle merci de votre disponibilité merci
de vos éclairages et on se retrouve tout
de suite avec la prochaine plénière
autour de notre ministre jacqueline
gourault